- [Narrator] The Mezquita has
always been a spiritual place,
but has not always been
occupied by the same religion.
Nowhere else in the world
will you find a cathedral
built inside the walls of a mosque.
Originally the site of a
temple to the Roman god Janus,
the Mezquita was built as a mosque
after Córdoba came under Moorish rule
in the late seventh century.
Then, in 1236, the city of
Córdoba came under Christian rule
and the Mezquita was
converted to a church.
Four centuries later,
a cathedral was constructed in its center
and it became a home for
the town's Roman Catholics.
While the cathedral's an example
of classic Catholic Baroque architecture,
the majority of the
Mezquita's construction
is a result of the work
of Islamic architects.
Features like 856 columns
and symmetrical arches
give the illusion of infinite space.
These elements are examples
of why the Mezquita
is considered one of the
greatest accomplishments
in Islamic architecture in the world.
Today, it is a UNESCO World Heritage Site.
Over a million people visit every year
and after all its history,
it is now seen as a site
of religious significance to
both Catholics and Muslims.
(electronic chimes)